what if our moon had a twin seeing not
just one but two of these satellites in
the night sky might be spectacular but
how would this second moon affect the
ocean tides would months on earth become
longer or shorter and with these two
satellites inevitably collide to cause a
massive explosion this is what if and
here's what would happen if the earth
had two moons despite what you think the
earth isn't really the monogamous type
along with the moon earth has another
moon like companion a small asteroid
wandering around it but it's so far and
so small that it can only be considered
a quasi satellite to our planet in our
scenario we're talking to real moons
just like the earth had during its
formative period yep we likely had two
satellites once both of them formed when
a mars-sized proto planet slammed into
Earth and shattered into small pieces so
what exactly would happen if the earth
had another moon parked in orbit around
it let's assume our second moon would be
around 1,000 kilometers wide and about
one thirtieth
the mass of our current moon it would be
about the same distance from Earth -
just like the sister satellite our moon
had four and a half billion years ago
would we see this double moon from Earth
absolutely the second moon would just
appear about three times smaller still
it would be a spectacular view along
with two moons would come some big tides
the newly captured moon would have a
much smaller tidal effect than that of
our Moon but the tidal force from both
satellites combined would make waves
literally although those waves would be
bigger they wouldn't be devastatingly
big in the end I think surfers will be
pretty happy
the second moon might stay in Earth's
orbit for tens of millions of years
until eventually as the moon retreated
further from the earth it would
destabilize the other moon's orbit then
just like they did over four billion
years ago the two satellites would
collide in slow motion because they'd be
moving slowly towards each other the
debris from the collision wouldn't
shower back on earth the small moon
would splatter itself across our moon as
an extra layer of solid crust the new
mountains of crushed rock visible from
the near side of our moon would be the
only reminders of its existence now what
if the second satellite happened to be
the same size as the moon and orbited
the earth at half the lunar distance
this time things wouldn't be so pretty
the second moon alone would produce
tides eight times greater than what we
see right now that would force people
away from the coastal areas because the
difference between high and low tides
would now reach 300 meters constant
tidal flooding would shrink the
habitable area on earth but once we
adapted to this new world we'd get to
enjoy a beautiful double moon this time
the second satellite would look bigger
from Earth due to its closer orbit the
moons would also have different phases
which means we'd have to come up with
another way to measure a month and then
there's some worse news the two moons
would be slowly moving away from Earth
and eventually would crash into each
other
this collision would send to breed back
to earth it would be a shower of
meteorites of epic proportion and it
could wipe us out entirely whatever
debris didn't fall to earth would form
yet another new moon in earth's orbit at
that point a new posthuman life-form may
begin to evolve and become Earth's next
civilization but that's a story for
another what if
you